sysolak holding a round table today  focusing on assistance for  businesses and bringing back our economy  lieutenant governor kate marshall  treasurer zac conan and a group of small  business owners also on that virtual  call  their concerns assisting businesses and  employees who test positive for  coronavirus  and when small business owners and  employees can get the vaccine  as part of the governor's economic plan  he announced his intention  to allocate an additional 50 million  dollars to provide direct grant  assistance to small businesses  and create a small business advocacy  center  in addition to this resource center  connecting you with those grants we also  need to make sure  that going forward you can call and we  have a bat  phone with the pets grant pandemic  emergency technical support they  received application for more than 13  000 businesses representing a need of  almost  150 million dollars